Hayden is with us Hayden is in Columbus
Ohio hi Hayden how are you I am great
how are you doing better than I deserve
what's up so I'm hoping you can keep me
from doing something stupid that's
rattling around in my brain okay well I
was on your show back in August last
year and you were kind enough to send my
wife and I to FPU and we went through
that and so far we paid off about twelve
thousand dollars in debt good out of six
34 or 36 that we had and so recently a
couple months ago I started my own
business who are getting sick and tired
of the day-to-day working one to make my
own money full-time I'm full time I saw
hustle hustle
okay so I want to keep all my budget the
same and let the business just make me
some extra money for the for the debt
control okay so the equipment that I
currently have I'm using my 27 year old
truck to ship stuff expedited freight
car hauling stuff like that to make some
money and the truck repair costs and
then the amount of stuff that I can all
with my truck is not working out for the
business anymore I need to I've been
losing loads because I can't take them
and so I found a truck that I like it
used has 15,000 miles on it and it's
$50,000 and I wanted to get a loan to
get that truck in order to increase my
business absolutely not you've got to be
kidding me
I mean who did you call did you think
you called somebody else well I've got
friends and family telling me to do it
yes I'm a young person and family only
well your friends and family are broke
do you know how long it take you to make
$50,000 on the loads that you've turned
down I mean you're gonna have to take
loads to the moon and back place you've
got to be kidding me that's absolutely
ridiculous I mean if it was $5,000 you
know you could actually think about it
but I'm not gonna think about the debt
on it but in no way $50,000
not a chance no you haven't turned down
that much revenue just turn down the
revenue you can't do until you can and
do what you can do I can't do everything
I can do everybody has a limitation in
business there's always more if you're
doing a good job for people you always
have more business than you can get to
if you're doing a good job with your
marketing and obviously you are because
you're turning having to turn stuff away
so what's your twenty seven-year-old
truck worth it should fifteen hundred
dollars okay and you have a remaining
twenty thousand dollars in that too
since August you've only reduced twelve
thousand dollars
what's your household income fifty
thousand a year okay and how much money
have you made on this side business
after a truck repairs and other this
that and the other I'm having to keep
the 27 year old truck alive about a
grand well let's just pretend we didn't
have to keep the truck alive what was
your top line by about five grand in a
month okay five thousand dollars a month
yeah for Senate since when about exactly
a month ago when I started it oh so
you've done it for one month and you had
one set of repairs yeah and based on
this you're going to make a $50,000
purchase decision that's what I wanted
to do yeah yeah that way you were right
it was stupid when you started the
question you said keep you from doing
something stupid
I mean you hear your sell me one month
of track record and you're ready to
invest you know no way fix the truck
drive the truck fix the truck drive the
truck deliver stuff if you're not making
more than a thousand dollars a month
your side hustles not working and I
don't think you're I don't think your
repairs are going to run four grand a
month I think you had one set of repairs
that came up because you put a strain on
the old thing
and you know if you're spending four
grand a month you can save for ground
and buy a four thousand dollar truck and
you'd have three times the truck you've
got now but not a fifty thousand dollar
truck that's just freakin insanity man
hope I wasn't unclear hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content
and check out these other Greg clips
from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]